plus moderne mais aussi plus accessible
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
des yvelines se renouvelle elle a mis en
place de nouveaux dispositifs dont un
outil multilingue les usages et
malentendants ou ne parlant pas français
ont accès aux questions les plus souvent
posées dans leur langue
une première en france on a plusieurs
langues alors proposé il ya pas que le
français est la langue des signes
français bien évidemment mais il ya
aussi l'anglais il ya l'arabe voilà donc
on a des langues aussi qui sont utilisés
par nos assurés et pour lesquelles on
n'était pas en capacité de répondre
aujourd'hui on peut enfin leur apportent
leur appui
le dispositif prévoit d'intégrer des
langues supplémentaires en fonction de
la demande
autre nouveauté un espace libre service
facilite les démarches plus besoin
d'attendre pour effectuer les opérations
les plus courantes comme ici à
guyancourt la cpam des yvelines s'est
équipée pour répondre aux demandes de
ses assurés le délai d'attenté trop
longs nous accueille et et anciens voire
un peu vieillot c'est aussi pour nous
important pouvoir les accueillir dans de
bonnes conditions de façon à ce qu'ils
se sentent bien accueillis mais aussi à
ce que je puisse avoir le temps de
répondre à leurs questions donc c'est
pour ça que l'après midi ont maintenant
leur offre des rendez-vous ce qu'on ne
ferait pas jusqu'à présent c'est plutôt
pratique ça fait gagner du temps ça nous
évite de se déplacer pour venir que pour
une attestation imprimer une attestation
d'assurance maladie ou consulter ses
remboursements devient alors plus facile
dans les yvelines 15 sites sur l'e19
sont équipés de ces dispositifs
d'autres caisses françaises devraient
suivre la métamorphose
les usagers peuvent venir donner leur
avis sur les bornes de satisfaction